et notre invité ce soir c'est philippe
foussier le grand maître du grand orient
de france bonsoir bonsoir d'ordinaire
vous nous fermez vos portes à nous les
journalistes aujourd'hui à nous sont
ouvertes pourquoi est ce que c'est une
façon de redorer le blason des
francs-maçons alors que beaucoup
s'interrogent justement ces mots
pratique redorer le blason jeu précis
c'est indispensable notre blason n'est
pas si terne que ça mais nous avons
l'habitude de faire des réunions
publiques de faire des tenues ouverte et
donc là ça s'inscrit dans cette démarche
qui est la nôtre de d'expliquer ce que
nous faisons simplement pour démystifier
ou en réalité c'est vrai un certain
nombre de préjugés ou d'idées reçues qui
circulent autour de la franc-maçonnerie
donc voila nous ouvrons nos portes et
nous expliquons aux gens ce que nous
faisons on le voit effectivement donc
les portes ont été ouvertes de feu matin
pour ce temple de tartenson mais le
temple est vide vous continuez à les
laisser fermer lorsque yavo cérémonie
pourquoi amener quelque chose à cacher
et par une ronde
on n'a rien à cacher simplement quand on
travaille on se met en retrait c'est à
dire que on se met un peu en retrait du
chaos
on se met en retrait du la pression de
ce qu'on appelle le monde profane pour
essayer de réfléchir calmement pour
essayer de justement d'avoir un recul
d'avoir de faire un pas de côté comme
nous disons et donc nous avons besoin
pour cela d'être dans une dimension un
peu retirée mais ne vaut rien et se
voyait tout de même comprendre que les
gens puissent interroger
oui pour moi qui ont tant mystère autour
de ce que vous faites oui bien sûr bien
sûr parce que la franc maçonnerie depuis
qu'elle existe depuis trois siècles
elle a charrié beaucoup de beaucoup de
voilà d'interrogation au format sur son
rôle de fantasmes en effet et donc il
peut y avoir en effet ces interrogations
mais nous sommes là pour l'élever et
pour expliquer ce que nous faisons très
simplement il n'ya il n'y a là rien rien
de bien mystérieux parce que tout ce que
nous faisons en réalité on peut le
trouver dans les livres il suffit de se
documenter et donc il n'y a pas de
mystère de la franc maçonnerie
il ya simplement la nécessité pour les
francs maçons encore une fois de se
mettre en retrait pour travailler
quelques heures par mois et est ce qu'il
n'ya pas aussi le mystère du réseau on
entend dire souvent que vous favoriser
certains de vos membres dans certaines
situations délicates notamment
judiciaires qu'en est il exactement
ce sont des situations qui ont pu
exister qui sont marginales anecdotique
et en tout cas dont on n'a pas entendu
parler depuis très longtemps
s'agissant du grand orient de france en
particulier je crois la plupart des
obédiences maçonniques et bien sûr il
peut toujours il fait toujours il y
existait des parfois des pratiques
condamnables enfin c'est quand même très
marginal très anecdotique donc cet
internat femmes puisque vous êtes là et
man 2 de vous poser des questions parce
qu' on entend beaucoup se plaignent
aussi que soit la marque nico ailleurs
de la qualité de vos recrutements on en
est loin
semble-t-il de la franc-maçonnerie
d'antan qui était plutôt élitiste
qu'est ce que vous répondez aujourd'hui
qu'à ça eh bien écoutez on s'adresse
effectivement à tous le grand orient de
france est ouvert à tous et ouvert à
tous ça ne veut pas dire que il faut
d'abord avoir une très grande motivation
pour entre man comes from à cédric c'est
un engagement fort personnel c'est une
démarche initiatique comme nous disons
c'est pas simplement comme on adhère à
un syndicat une association un parti
politique c'est quelque chose de fort
parce que c'est un engagement qui va se
dérouler dans la durée donc il y à la
nécessité d'avoir une forte motivation
et puis après nous sélectionnons les
gens qui viennent à nous mais nous avons
le souci de recruter le plus largement
possible dans les couches de la
population les plus diverses notamment
socialement il ya la question le temple
donc sera à nouveau ouvert samedi pour
la conférence que vous animerez ce sera
donc sur quel thème et quel sera le
public
cibler et bien engagement initiatique et
engagement républicain démarche
initiatique engagement républicain et
notre souci c'est de faire comprendre
effectivement au public profane lors il
y aura sans doute beaucoup de francs
maçons dans la salle il y aura aussi des
profanes donc qui seront invités par des
francs maçons certains et qui
connaissent la franc maçonnerie par ce
biais pour expliquer justement à quoi
sert la franc maçonnerie ce qu'elle fait
quels sont les travaux des francs maçons
et donc il y aura un certain nombre de
choses que nous pourrons dire à cette
occasion et notamment ce que nous
voulons faire prévaloir c'est l'idée de
fraternité est dans un monde où il ya
plus en plus de tensions de violence et
bien nous voulons nous indiquer une voie
possible pour mieux s'entendre entre
tous c'est la fraternité
merci et fait des poussées pour la
réunion